i'm delighted to have the opportunity of
talking about my research here i'm not
going to view from
the university of technology city the
title of my talk is sample efficient
identity testing and independence
testing of quality
property testing considers the following
question for x in
s we want to decide whether x is in p or
by local queries
this region testing was initialized by
car person at
1890 who considers the question that
given
samples from what or more unknown
probability distribution we want to
decide whether you satisfy a certain
probability or not
uh formally is like for x in
s we want to determine whether x is in p
or x is in s minus q
with high probability distribution
testing has attracted lots of attention
in the community of tcs for instance the
identity testing problem the
independence testing problem and the
conditional independence testing problem
many techniques and
ideas smart ideas from comes from
analyzing l-tunnel quantum property
testing
the problem is given
copies from one or more unknown quantum
state
we want to decide whether you satisfy a
certain property this problem was
initialized by alexander however in
1970s different from classical priority
testing
we have to deal with a great variety of
measurements
considering the quantum property testing
problem
as follows given uncopies of the
dimensional quantum state rule and
property p we want to verify whether
rows x i p or far from satisfy
p during the measurement setting we need
to design a
measurement with dimension d to the n
apply on the end copies of
state rho and output data
data would with high probability that i
will characterize where the row sets up
here or far from the same direction
for independent measurement setting
we're measuring
each copies of a row independently
and gathering all the classical outcomes
from the measurements
and the complete data
comparing these two uh sampling method
joint measurement
could have lower complexity but the
measurement dimension is due to the k
therefore it's hard to
implement independent measurement
which has a slightly larger complexity
but the management dimension is d which
makes it easy to implement
quantum property testing has attracted
lots of retention recently
for instance democracy problem
considering about the outputting a good
estimation of given state and spectrum
testing problem
with whose goal is to output a good
estimation of the spectrum given state
and and i didn't test it as well as the
shadow conclusion online
um think about
the sampling method difference between
the classical properties and quantum
property testing
quantumly we usually use the shoe vowel
duality to minimize the
sample complexity but classically the
only sampling method is contained
therefore smart
ideas and techniques from collective
property testing are not used in quantum
property testing
so in this work we design
an independent measurement which
preserves the l2 now
so for the dimensional column system
there's a measurement m such that
the resulting probability distributions
p and q for any two columns zero and
sigma
satisfy that the l2 distance between p
and q
is e is the l2 number between row and
sigma divided d plus one
and the l two norm of p and q
are both no more than square two divide
d plus one
therefore we have the framework of
solving the quantum property testing
problem for l one
so first we apply the measurement and
translate the problem into the l2 norm
problem for classical property testing
and we recall the classical algorithm
for l2 norm
then we therefore
we according to our relation we have a
quantum algorithm for l2 norm and
therefore
we solve the l1 norm by recording the
the
relation between l2 and l1
so using this from a framework we have
so we can have
some results on the quantum property
testing for instance
the the deterministic
property of deterministic
algorithm for identity testing
so in this talk i will focus on this one
and
as well as the lower bound part for the
joint measurement uh of
independence testing
so for the identity testing problem so
we want to distinguish whether two
columns 0 and sigma equal or
the distance between one sigma is
greater than usual
so we actually should uh one can show
that the
d d square copies of one sigma enough
simply because we call that the result
of cdbv
we show that
we show that order of b divided some
square copies of p
and q is enough to distinguish
p equals q and the two number between p
and q is greater than epsilon where b is
the maximum of the two norm of p
and q to the probability distribution
together with our result
and for independence testing so here the
two system quantum state rule one two is
called independent
if row one two is row one ten zero two
and the goal is to distinguish that
whether row one two equals row one times
row two from the
row one two minus sigma one tensor sigma
two greater than epsilon for any
sigma and sigma 2. actually we only need
to distinguish
row 1 2 equals to row 1 times root 2
from row 1 to minus row 1 times row 2
equation that hips on device 3.
and then we just call the identity
testing
and similar to the identity identity
testing of collection independence of
collection and the conditional events
that we have with many results
and for the low boundary for the journey
of joint measurement
for independence testing actually we can
actually show that
uh sigma a citation d1 tends to d2
divided
some square copies are needed for
independence testing in d1 tensor d2
system so
we will use this uh result by uh
ryan and john wright at 2015
that uh 100d divided some square copies
are sufficient and
1.15 d device
if some square copies are necessary to
test whether row is i
divided d or rho minus i divided d is
greater than epsilon
so if both d1 d2 are very large we can
employ the independent testing
to test whether one two is i want as the
d1 test i2 test d2 by
first test
whether row one is i1 divide d1 or rho 1
minus i 1 divided by 1 is greater than
epsilon 1 and
then which has the weather rho 2 equals
i 2 divided d2 or
[Music]
rho 2 divided i 2 divided the root 2
minus i 2 divided d2 is greater than
epsilon 2
then it has the independence of r12
by careful they chosen new zealand one
and zone two here we should go but
it does not work for large d1 and small
d2 because
but step one and the maximum mixed
testing are
at the same order so we think about the
dimensional
dimension spilling technique
so we consider two by d system i
regarded as a two
tensor two tests that has two system and
we split in other words we split d into
log d
qubit system and we can use the
independence testing of two times a d
system to test whether a
one plus log lead qubits state rho is i
two times a
divide two tens of tensor by we test the
each row i whether to see whether rho i
equals
i two d by two so alpha and then we test
whether rho is independent
through any one versus log d cut
and will use the the observation that m
plus one cubic state is
if some close to be independent for any
one
versus m partition then is five and
epsilon close to the
m plus one position parted independence
and that's it thank you